Christine you're piercing your way
you're bringing up clips girl about yeah
the Christine sound where's Christine
you're more than a YouTube jockey you're
a producer of the show executive
producer Christine I can see now I'm
gonna be somebody babe well guess what
boys the videos don't play themselves
pause start stop finish it's all the
same to you I'm in a tornado of command
Jacob's gone and blue is drunk and black
who's doing something up social media
[Music]
like just a girl getting coffee for some
people with the ass donkey laughs
I actually had the pleasure of opening
for free Brian at Caroline's before he
jumped that make Peter jump the last one
such a funny mum we I think I told you
this on an oddball tour but uh they told
me you want to work with Brian Regan
this weekend yes for sure yeah
Caroline's goes up but you have to be
like squeaky clean and I was like yeah
I'll figure it out like for sure and on
the very first show was uh I was going
squeaky clean there's a guy in the
audience too so I think he was gone
before you before you even got on stage
but like you would just give him the two
meters go and it was trying to like go
back at him with like that's gotta be in
a real jerk huh I bet you I'm trying to
be clear I'm like yeah why don't you go
home and have sex with a man clean dirty
weirdo
I came back in the green room and as
grad told you that my favorite thing
about this story I thought was the
coolest thing ever would you went you
could curse I doesn't matter me the club
was Gipper's came down sword I was like
Caesar you are a real bad guy oh I don't
like the kind of person you are at all
loud you seem like a filthy man a bad
man I I opened for Nate bargatze in West
Virginia and he was like hey man you got
to be clean and I thought that I always
kind of thought that thing of like how
clean do you have to be so I cut out all
my curse words but I said god damn and a
woman in the second row just goes he
said she and that that yeah
tailspin because I was like what else in
my head all I could think when I was for
the rest of the set was what other words
are bad that I don't know well I I do
like to work with people who are not
super dirty in front of me but I don't
like to censor people yeah sure so
there's a difference between booking
somebody who works clean and asking
somebody who you just booked hey you
have to work clean tonight yeah because
I don't like throwing that on people I
don't want to censor I don't want to
censor you right right no for sure no
that's that's what I loved about when we
talk in the back you were like I
wouldn't tell you how to deal you which
I thought was such a cool thing that is
a very cool thing
I had another comic before who was just
I worked with him before he went on the
theaters no it always blew my mind
when I went on stage I wasn't very dirty
but I current when I got off stage he
asked me to come in the back to go I
need you to be squeaky clean and it was
one of those like this guy was getting
ready to go huge too so the audience was
so excited when he touches the stage it
wouldn't matter what happened yeah same
thing like you know with the you Brian I
I don't think I've ever told you a story
that because I was so mortified as a
young kid that same weekend you know
this I know this story and this is this
isn't yeah this is great story I mean
terrible story it's a great story but
the fact that Brian's on the show and
you could tell it to them I think you've
told the story before on the shore on
the show but it's a thing of being
opening for someone and having just a
colossal it's a real story of
the beware who you tell like yeah I'll
get you and your friends or whoever into
the show right I when I first got to New
York just trying to find work that
wasn't difficult and also as a fat
insecure guy I tried to get a job at a
weird strip club right across street and
Caroline's I think it was more of a
whorehouse
no booze and it was very bizarre small
place within the women in there were
scraggly but I when I went in there and
talked to the guy and told him I was a
comedian I became friendly with the
bartender guy mm-hmm and he would come
see me do comedy show us once in a while
the guy who owned the place was a much
more seedy gentleman he was a guy who
can believe that yeah and I said it was
the expression it was funny gentleman
I'm pretty you know I'll go into a dark
weird place with things and thinks
things are interesting or even as dirty
is great however this guy would just do
with the thing when the girls walk by oh
is it very like look at this new one
like you know I grab an ass cheek or it
was very odd but they asked me when you
were in 10th they can come see the show
so I said I'll probably saw that but
Caroline's was nice to me and they gave
him four tickets you guys we're also
gonna bring uh four of us it's great
watching
I'm just watching Bryan's face be SS you
say go so this is one of the worst human
beings ever
waterings three wildcard line it was
more the bartender brought three people
one of them being the owner and two of
the girls but I did not know it was
gonna happen
where do they sit them I've watched a
hundred plus sets of yours
from TV alive to that weekend I've never
seen in the middle of one of your bits
you just broke and were like miss like
you're talking how rude you're being you
gave her like a talking to which was
legitimate and I'm watching in the
background oh my god this is gonna be so
like the club is gonna be like I mean it
couldn't have a piece of paper and the
thing says more guests now you see now
Brian's on stage and you're in the back
and for those that don't know Caroline's
it's like a back and then it's a hallway
so you're actually around the corner so
you're listening to Brian on stage did
you know when he broke his bit that he
was talking to the people he brought a
hundred percent there was no one else
who could have possibly been it was an
audience that was all there to see him
specifically yeah sold out they put my
guest for some reason right in the front
of people that were like I guess you
know like I think we're gonna come see
they were more going for like the
hook-up of me because when you said
earlier that they wanted to come see the
show I immediately thought I don't think
they're phantom eyes they might worried
enough of hearing this at all
and I think this guy that was pawing on
these young women go man I want to hear
jokes about doughnuts he goes come here
he's wholesome doughnuts sprinkled joke
he goes come here panting come here
penny you ever heard a good
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you're on zygotic after you like
jokes about station wagons filthy my
comedy clean man nothing gets me clean
observation and a bit dirty girl he says
something astute like it's all about the
juxtaposition of life you don't I mean
you know or you own a whorehouse and are
on the board of st. Jude's well you know
when you're on stage can you feed coz at
this point you you you know what an
audience feels like that's their to see
you when something like that is in the
front row can you like I was just at the
Albany funny bone it's gonna be a
baffling at that plant yeah that's what
I'm saying dude back up I think I
remember that night Oh probably cool
I'll tell you why remembers Dora lines
and there was a woman in the front who
was like just out of control and it was
a prostitute that I'm wrong I'm sorry
what do you do for a living I would have
known how great is it to find out that a
heckler years later was just a bad boy
the best part of the story is yet to
come in a moment was all I can't wait
for now is the show to be over so I can
go out and I'm going to yell at these
guys like out in the lobby for like what
the what would you do that yeah I
got you in here as a guest like you're
making me an asshole
it takes forever for them to come out
and then just the guys end up coming out
I didn't go out there I guess fast
enough and the guys come out and they go
there right away they're like sorry man
we're really sorry and I go yeah man you
should be sorry that's crazy
I got you I'll give it a speech I have
prepared I hooked you guys up and you
and then you're gonna just talk during
the show and he goes talk oh you weren't
in there for the very end where you I
went what do you mean he goes a lady
makes a substantive yours said to one of
the prostitutes she goes wow thank you
you really ruined that
show for me and then this Porto Rican
prostitute which is like bid and just
decked her in the face and then the
knives came out stopped picking up
strays after that gnarly character the
next night so now we're to Friday I'm
under the Manhattan Bridge I'm talking
with some real sketchy fellas they seem
cool though I'm doing a show tonight if
you want to get some free tickets I say
go to the early one for person guest
list and it was the four people that
legitimately I did not know this story
you don't get crazy people it shows now
right night no not usually
no no especially if I'm performing
somewhere where that's why you would be
coming yeah I'm not in a comedy club so
if I'm in a a venue where you'd have to
have it you'd be coming there to see me
yeah yeah and also with theatres too
like the drinking is not constantly
coming around to you it's not money made
off the or me there's money made but
it's not a bar business right once
you're in the theaters still which is
like which makes people not get so
annihilated which is generally what
do you think the last time like a stack
of fries was served ripped into a ribeye
dunk a chicken fingers I remember being
at Caroline's one time and this is when
I was at the tail end of doing the
comedy clubs and there was a guy at the
front table same table that yours yes
they some say it's haunted
[Laughter]
possessed and it was a guy heavyset guy
and I was I was doing pretty good and
the front table you can see there in the
pool of light and waitress brought a
cheeseburger in front of him and set the
cheeseburger down and his eyes like
rolls into the back of his head and the
cheeseburger immediately became the
headliner yeah and he'd like completely
stop looking at me and just turned and
and spent about ten minutes just loving
every moment of that cheeseburger and it
wasn't and and I just remember laughing
to myself going this is so bizarre yeah
you know like its comedy to a point and
then you have and then you're doing
comedy over people eating and then when
he was done with his cheeseburger he
like slid it away and looked back up at
me as if all right almost every week at
least at one show where I just look down
I just see somebody exactly cutting into
a wedge salad or something why would you
have something that's gonna cover the
table and bacon pieces do you want me
the thing that doesn't make sense is um
I can get over the food in the drink
it's when people are doing group long
division while I'm trying to do a bit
and they have the checks and they're
like you just watch that math happen and
you're like I can't win in this you want
to say one of you pay the tab will that
work it out work it out later but to
figure it out there is the most
insulting thing as a performer going
really and you can hear them going no no
you
I ordered the second pair but then I
cancelled it I was by this week it was
but you didn't you couldn't even tell
what they were saying was just and you
go are you guys are you guys good over
there and they go we're just figuring it
out just you keep going away you don't
worry about us why I say could you
imagine if you went to a Broadway play
right and in 20 minutes before it's over
some guy crouched down next to you and
said it's
[Laughter]
what happens in a comedy club every
night they get in their pockets while
you're watching the final act of a
Shakespearean that's the beauty of the
theater though is like it this is again
they're always coming to see like you
particularly or from recommend day
whatever it is you know they're coming
to see a comedy show where to come I
mean like bombing or just hearing
silence in a room and hearing the sounds
of you know a guy pulling gristle out of
his mouth to wrap in a napkin or
something or just you know just the
sounds of fries being like pulverized by
teeth jarring I still hear it sometimes
I heard when it goes completely silent
you just hear someone swishing around I
skim it like you're impressing a bomb
like you're pressing a bomb yeah yeah no
like is that all you have Mr Bond yeah
and like you don't you don't you you
look at him like you don't hear that you
don't hear what you're doing there's
like you suck I don't know maybe make me
like you more I went to a years ago I
was on vacation and went to like this
little town like they had a play you
know like a local community play and it
was all these long tables with chairs
and whoever put on the play I was just
like in this old wooden like rustic
structure and but it's fun to see stuff
like that well they put bowls of chex
mix so everybody sits down the whole
play people were chewing on chance man
you know it adds to Shakespeare loud bar
snacks yeah put some licorice nibs in
that bowl or something soft you do
anything and entranced ensure that
chairs were like metal
you know metals a concrete floor so
anybody that sat down or got up to use
the restroom and then when they did sit
down
and this is a great production it really
sucks this room out Louis do you
remember in your early days like just
hell gig still to this time een I
started in the black comedy circuit so I
have so many just from being the one
white guy in a place that would go
haywire but then let alone then jumping
and like the open mic scene and
performing a basements of plays they're
places they don't think you should have
a microphone even you guys know Betty's
fireside Betty's fireside was a gig in
New Jersey and it was notorious for
being a rough room and I had heard about
it before I even moved to New York City
and so I kind of looked forward to
eventually playing Betty's fireside yeah
Betty's fireside was a place where they
had like a band and then in front of the
band was the bartenders and then the bar
and then the audience the audience was
all standing so for comedy night nobody
was seated everybody it was just packed
with him and I heard that the room can
be rough so they wanted me to be the
first comedian so I said alright fine
and I said who does the offstage intro
and they looked at me like they said you
just get on stage and start the show so
I was gonna be the first of the three
comedians and I said alright and I
thought I had like enough chops where I
could handle a rough room and so I just
start walking up the steps to get on the
stage and this guy from the corner in
the back yells you suck and I'm not at
the mic yet I can't defend myself so I
have to like look and wink like hey I'll
get to you in a second a politician
point where you go I hear give me a
second I gotta get to the sound system
there are issues there are issues sir
I'm still walking to the mic and a guy
from the other side said we think you
suck from over here too so I was like
double-barreled and I got to the mic and
tried to nice-guy it which is was the
worst move yeah you know no the fear oh
man like you know I hit with the angle
of hey share with you verbally put your
hands on your head that's not right come
on guys no that's not right yeah and
they just they just buried me and it was
one of the first times that I didn't do
my entire time everybody was supposed to
do a half hour and I'm on stage ten
minutes in and I'm going this ain't
doing any more to clean up yeah who was
following me like he's gonna watch 30
minutes oh that's he's gonna leave you
know there is that funny thing when
you're watching someone have a rough
time in front of you and a part of you
is like you know you feel terrible for
me one but then it's like oh my half
they jump like early it's like it's
gonna throw the whole thing off you know
like that's gotta be a scary thing
there's been times where I've watched
people eat it so hard that you want them
to jump early you want to back it off
come on no I don't bet some saying you
cuz you don't want them to like have
toys in the role time of like man exact
route my store the people who don't know
me you're gonna come in here thinking
like this might be this the whole time
yeah yeah cuz it's amazing still you
know I was just at the Albany funnybone
which is in a mall and you really look
out and you get like 30% of you were
here to see me and everyone else just
got a coupon what the MC this weekend
goes have you there was just I don't you
know I'm just coming home on Sunday and
I was like are you staying for the
Sunday show and he goes no it's a it's a
hypnotist and I was like oh yeah that's
like looks like a Sunday show at a club
right and he goes you grope for a
hypnotist I was like yeah you have it
and he was like blown away you forget
all the crazy that you opened while
all these long all these mall clubs it
really is add to the ridiculous menu
eating now add like four bags from foot
action USA declares filled in I filled
in for a comedy hypnotist yeah and
nobody told me the audience thought that
I was going to do comedy hypnosis and I
just ate it for an hour and I walked
offstage I get that flop sweat and the
first thing you want to do is go to the
bar yourself a double jack and ginger or
something and somebody came up to me and
said how come you didn't make us act
like chickens you know they showed me
the table tent that was on every table
comedy hypnosis night nobody including
me as it relax your minds and prepare
for coming more than a quarter of the
people in the audience after twenty
minutes was like this guy is really long
on the foreplay the keywords station
wagon yeah that's crazy but it
was it was like this innocent question
when the MCS that where he was like have
you open all buddy I've opened for a
silent clown and his wife plays the
piccolo is they when you meet old like a
comic who's been around a road like TC
Hatter still out there you really forget
as a community's my favorite thing ever
was chips Cooney I was he was featuring
for me and Finley once we're outside of
Philly and as he was tying as Katie goes
so what have you been up to I said I
just opened for Dave Attell on the
insomniac tour on the East Coast and he
goes yeah goes like like theaters and
stuff I go yeah is like a bunch of
theaters as he's tying his magician
escape he goes I'm good see I kids doing
theaters now and then he ran back in the
room you know whatever 30 minutes later
in his underwear with a fake stain
in holding his tuxedo his hands and he
goes
hot crowd you know the thing about
opening for so we're subbing for
somebody who you didn't know you were
subbing for that was always the best
with the black circuit ski trip shows
yeah
they would book them and get these high
budgets because they would be you know
like Chris Tucker and Martin Lawrence
are coming and then they would get the
budget and then pay me and whoever I
wanted to bring like $700 and you'd get
there and you big hey we're the
comedian's ago I thought uh Chris it was
like not that level but it was like they
always those names from my Def Jam that
we're coming and there's like now not
only is it not them it's also two white
guys who didn't know that's what this is
what was happening huh yeah and it would
just go almost nightmares every time
it's rough I mean that's just gotta be
promoters just being like all we could
there's some stacking money yeah they're
getting like ten thousand dollar budgets
I'm paying out $700 I know if you would
do two hundred night you'd get like a
thousand I don't want to hold you up
here to Lonnie in a long day of stuff
yeah I mean you're a legend you're
hilarious thank you I think somewhere
thank you very much man yeah yeah the
kind words and thanks for bringing back
the horrific memory such a thing it's my
number one story of like you gotta watch
who you invite to a shower
[Music]